We know the values of 4 and negative 3 would make this left-hand side equal to
0. We can use these two values of x equals 4 and x equals negative 3 to create
three separate intervals on a number line. These three intervals may contain
the numbers that are solutions to our quadratic inequality. For example, all of
the numbers to the left of negative 3 will either make this statement positive
or negative. We can use a test point within this interval or a test value to
find out. For example, I could use the value x equals negative 4 to determine
whether or not this left side is positive or negative. We want this side to be
greater than 0. So, when I plug in negative 4, I would want this to be a
positive number. If that's the case, then every number from negative 3 and to
the left will make this statement positive, which means we include it in our
solution set. So, rewriting my original inequality here, I can plug in the
value of negative 4 in for x. When we evaluate this, we'll get 8 is greater
than 0. We know the statement is true, so we know all the values less than
negative 3 are solutions to our original inequality. If you're in disbelief
that all the other numbers in here work, then try plugging in negative 5 or
something like negative 10 in for the value of x. You should wind up with a
positive number on this side. Here, I've gone ahead and shown you another check
for x equals negative 8. If we use this value at interval I, we'll wind up with
a statement 60 greater than 0. We know this is true, so again, this is part of
our solution set. We don't need to test every value in interval I, we only
needed to test one of them. You try testing interval II and interval III. Pick
one value for x in this region and in this region. Plug them into your original
inequality, and see if you come out with a true statement. If true, then that
interval is part of the solution. If false, then that interval will not be part
of our solution. Also, as a hint, think of an easy value to plug in that's
between negative 3 and positive 4. What do you think is the easiest value to
use in between these two numbers?